grapes with rudy' well what do you start
it's not really a gripe I think that you
didn't it's a it's sabotage
it's the world on a gripe I it's just
kind of word it cuz I talked about it on
bad friends as well so I don't even know
why I should talk about it now but
actually I may not be privy to this what
happened I'll tell you I'll tell you
I'll tell you then um you know I I like
my I like food and I spend sometimes
money on food and I I you know maybe I'm
fat and maybe I worship food too much
but you know I I'll go to a nap and I'll
order fancy foods from all over the
country from different states I like to
try things out and III order pies and if
you ever want a delicious pie people
chicken and mushroom pepper steaks she's
smiling right now because she hasn't
really jet group yeah she doesn't really
get the magnitude of her of her offenses
mm-hmm but you know I love my pie anyway
so you know you get him delivered from
all over the country so you know they
come to the door and we have a rule in
the house where she has to disinfect
everything before it comes inside the
house that's her job is to disinfect
things and I love her so much she's a
sweet girl gets straight A's I'm so
proud of her and she no don't roll your
eyes at me please
I know GPA 1.0 she started following
this actor boy in high school and I you
know this actor Brian Oh his name and he
was older I'm not gonna say his name but
she followed this actor she went to
school and she followed this actor who
goes through school he's a theater was a
theater guy cutest [ __ ] you know me
hello got us Southern California Tony
Hawk kind of vibe to him a young Yakov
Smirnoff knocking um Weird Al Yankovic I
mean oh that's what he kind of looks
like yeah so it's a combination between
Tony Hawk and Weird Al Yankovic but he's
a young kid and she followed him on
social media on Instagram and he didn't
follow her how long has it been a month
she has not followed her back and it
really I want to tweet at the guy I want
to follow him and make a message and go
if you don't [ __ ] I will bury you
I know it's not right but that's my as a
father that's what I want [ __ ] follow
her back you know what Bobby threatened
to do yesterday was follow the kid so
this is we were all about to watch a
movie and he's like you know what I'm
just gonna go ahead and follow him I'm
like I don't think that's the right move
at all hey I wanted to follow him have
me follow back and just do a direct
message and go yo do it just you know on
the side on the side you know I mean
follow her back that's so do that
because I realize you guys top senses
that was my gut instinct yeah that was
my goodness you know what his gut
instinct was when we first started
dating his gut instinct was to follow
all of my exes usually wrong my gut
instincts that's why I don't ever follow
them
oh no I go against my gut do the
opposite so she's in love with this boy
and it's a crush and but you know I you
know then I proposed you know I setup
for Gilbert you know him ray Nia
Sammy yeah yeah so I sent so I called
ray me last night I'm her type though
visually no well that's why I bet
backfired because I go ray me send me
three photos of you so he sent three
photos right and I go I called him right
back and I said you gotta lose weight I
can't do that that's so mean he's all
she's so cute to me he's all cheeks he's
very cute
boy and that was so mean that you said
for him to lose weight he doesn't need
to lose weight he looks milk glands in
his titties he says every time you play
I always say that squirt me some milk
out your [ __ ] titties but don't you
find it like a little bit weird that
you're trying to beg arrange to children
today not to children to adult young
adults today
it's like traditional matchmake back in
the day you know I I'm not 14 Oh mommy
you sound like a Filipino mama said but
I wasn't making some suggestions hmm
because she's like has his crush on this
like actor boy from school and I go well
I have an alternative didn't she try to
offer her also give her the option for
trauma Todd who is trauma Todd who is
the trauma of a trauma Todd no you saw a
video okay guys so Gilbert and I we all
play war zone and I play with a guy
named Ray me but I also play with a guy
I can't see his name because he wants to
keep be kept a secret but his name is I
called him Todd and then I just call him
trauma Todd I don't know why earlier and
trauma Todd um he lives in England and
he's a very talented skateboarder hmm
and so I had a video of him
skateboarding on my phone right and so
kalila saw he looks like a kind of like
a deformed Harry Styles I don't see what
that's what I'd say oh oh he looks like
a regular ass you know regular Harry
Styles was deformed but um but so either
way I got guys that I'm gonna set her up
with let me go back to the [ __ ] thing
no the pan berry pie no that's not I'd
like to also just say one more thing
before we move forward yeah so you guys
none of you guys think it's weird when
parents set their kids up with other
people this is just the parent thing it
seems normal at least in my culturally
in my experience that Filipinos do it a
lot but I was dating Cindy and my
grandpa is still trying to set me up
with women in the Philippines like I'm
like you know I'm bitter with Cindy
forever he's like I know but just in
case like it takes what I'm literally
telling you that what a propose sir
you're offering Filipino women to me you
know what I had we go back to the pan
Barry Joel what's pan Barry that's the
name of the company i order pan berry
pies from an app called gold belly
they're not sponsoring us but it's a
very good app and you can get food from
anyway and so you know we can't I can't
just affect the food that comes here if
that's Julie
his job and I've said this I said this
before but I'm gonna say it again so
that it never happens again and she's in
complete denial about it and she's think
it's fine and all that [ __ ]
so I tell her the PI's are here and she
goes okay uncle detail or whatever it
might be
yeah okay uncle theta there it is pan
berries mm-hmm oh those are delicious
okay uh right and so you know I don't
know how food works in the Philippines
but um when you leave it out in the Sun
here in America you know it if
something's frozen because of just the
Sun it melts and when you leave it out
there for two days the shit's gonna melt
Oh two days so but she doesn't tell me
right cuz I let it go because I think
that she was responsible she's
responsible she's responsible girl for
two days she leads him out there and
then so she doesn't tell me she puts
them in the freezer as if I'm not gonna
notice oh you know I didn't know I know
until I go I say you know sometimes Papa
wakes up and goes pamper party Oh a
little pie right I go in to the freezer
and I pick up a pie now the pies are all
about this big and they're in a plastic
wrapper and it tells you on the wrapper
you know mushroom and chicken or
whatever I might be right but these this
batch is you see the pie but outside of
the pie you see brown gravy it frozen
now it's no longer in the pie all right
the [ __ ] is outside of the pie and
there's no way to put frozen brown gravy
back inside the [ __ ] pots like a
prolapsed anus yeah you can still put
those back I had three of them you need
tweezers some pliers sure it's a [ __ ]
it would be a [ __ ] - a guild is you
can't put [ __ ] back into the but exact
that's better yeah I am you can just
push that back but I leave it out for a
couple of days especially during
Halloween so I can play like you know
mean animal
she says when I have a prolapse but I
was like keep it out for a couple of
days so arm so now when you eat a pie
and I just had one before this podcast
you know I baked it basically what you
have in it is the pie right and the meat
because the meat didn't seep through
yeah so it's just no juice no juice no
yeah and you know what a pie is let's be
honest let's be real for once on this
[ __ ] podcast sure what's inside a
[ __ ] pie is a stew is supposed to be
a steal yeah
it's a thick gravy like stew so then I
and I gently pointed out I go you know
these pies you know she goes it's that
gravy
it's oil that was pretty good improv
just pick up something do i I say to her
oh do I did I order oil pie high on the
packaging does it say chicken with oil
and chicken in canola no do you no
reason why it doesn't [ __ ] say that
it's because there's no [ __ ] all right
I love you
you're doing great job in the household
and everyone's saying online to be nicer
to Rudy I'm getting direct messages you
got to be nice or I'm done with you I'm
done with bad friends I'm done with
Tiger belly if you're not nicer to Rudy
and this is me being nice that's why I
didn't [ __ ] do anything you know even
the fat pies and I'm gonna tell you this
right now as we speak I ordered another
batch okay
are you mad hmm but she's doing a great
job
I honestly know let's say it's positive
things yeah she's loving with this guy
let's shut the far side but a lot of
guys have crushes on her on the Internet
you know they do I know I guess that's
not real life is it it's not real life I
mean if he wants to make it real live
mmm that'd be kind of young she's too
young
she's too young you know wait wait she's
too young to date in general IIIi don't
want it
there's the dad vibes kicking in yeah I
don't want it yet I think she was she I
want her to get through school I want to
graduate from high school
can you graduate from high school and
then we'll figure out your future I'm so
the opposite yeah I'm always like we
talking to you these days let me see the
pictures would should we set up like a 6
feet apart they like it's also very mom
though to be like listen up a playdate
we have an unhelpful advice Gil Gil
those stories with Bobby at kalila
[Music]